[Music]
most of what we call politics really
revolves around the question of what you
need to do to make a country richer
rather than ask this of any specific
country let's imagine designing a
country from scratch how could you make
it as rich as possible
suppose the brief was to design rich
land an ideal wealth creating society
what would be the chief characteristics
you'd need to build into this society
what would a nation look like that was
ideally suited to success in modern
capitalism traditional economics guides
us to eight core requirements for
Richland military security and law and
order lack of corruption in institutions
low amounts of red tape around
employment legislation and taxation a
technically well-educated mobile
flexible labor force a high-grade
infrastructure and good
telecommunications fair transparent and
competitive markets reliably enforceable
contracts and low corporation tax
probably between ten and fifteen percent
but aside from these eight factors there
is one thing that invariably makes a
critical difference to the wealth of
societies what we might call cultural
factors to make Richland properly rich
you'd need to ensure that a number of
cultural factors were firmly embedded in
a national mentality here are some of
these wealth inducing attitudes in
Richland at parties the first thing
people want to know is what do you do
according to how you answer people are
either delighted to see you or swiftly
abandon you by the peanuts in Richland
what's on your business card is simply
who you are all the other stuff what you
were like as a child what you think of
late at night who your parents are don't
really matter in Richland friendships
are usually linked to work and involve
covert status rivalries if you fall
behind your friends might drop you you
have to invest an enormous amount of
effort in your career not merely to make
money but so that you can have a
functioning social identity
so that people will be nice to you in
richland parents place a tremendous
emphasis on educational achievements
children come away feeling not just that
it's nice to do well in exams but that
they are more lovable human beings more
worthy of existence if they triumph at
school especially in maths and science
you therefore learn early on that love
comes from successful performance the
more you achieve that kind of people
will be to you in richland everyone is
encouraged from a young age to imagine
that they might one day perhaps by
around 33 be the richest person in the
country if they work hard posters of
rich and famous people adorn the walls
of primary schools the national anthem
is called I can do it an ecstatic
rendition of human possibility this
keeps the workforce highly motivated
dreams of successful entrepreneurship
abound but by middle age most people in
richland have by definition failed to
measure up to the exalted hopes once
placed in them they keep their regrets
hidden however and have quietly
prescribed tranquilizers and
antidepressants people don't sleep very
well in richland they're often up at 4
a.m. their worries all relate to their
careers that's because market capitalism
in richland is very efficient efficiency
means constant innovation and rivalry
the weaker players in any field are
always driven out of business swiftly
and without mercy stock market is
ruthless about punishing
underperformance normally on a quarterly
basis in richland everything is geared
towards the needs of the consumer there
must be low prices there has to be
excellent customer service shops have to
be open at all hours there can be no
sacrosanct high holidays or weekends
even though most people are both
consumers and producers in richland
they're taught to think of themselves
primarily as consumers in their minds
they're multiple woes as producers
carefully disassociated from the scale
of their expectations as considered
[Music]
there is news everywhere in Richland on
websites phones and 24-hour channels and
it's always catastrophic citizens
thereby learned that the world is
incredibly unsafe and a terror accident
and cruelty await at every turn
there is utter silence about anything
positive every encounter with the media
leaves one suspecting that the only way
to protect oneself is through the
accumulation of ever larger sums of
money in Richland people don't take many
holidays generally they're very
self-denying and scared what might
happen if they don't remain in the
office long enough they get up early a
suspicious of any kind of indulgence and
have sandwiches at their desks for lunch
on the other hand they're very
interested in paying a lot for what they
called fun they pay a significant
premium to have a car that can go twice
the legal speed limit and for flying far
away on holiday many times a year
activities that don't cost much like
going for long walks around the local
neighborhood or writing poetry are seen
as unimpressive slightly eccentric
things though many of Richland
psychologists speak of the benefit of
parents spending time with their small
children most children are brought up by
star from low-wage countries while their
parents go to work
this lack of secure attachment does
wonders for the children in turn they
grow up anxious eager to please and
desperate to attain security through
work in Richland there are powerful
currents of fashion around most things
or thickness your TV screen has what
kind of ethnicity of food you eat what
models of phone you talk on people can
get rapidly to satisfied with their
current possessions and quickly excited
by new products it feels very important
to be up-to-date it's a serious blow to
one self-esteem to feel that one is
missing a trend you can get into trouble
if your phone is more than three years
old people speak highly of thinking for
yourself but shaped like behavior is
better for the shops
every society has famous people in it
but Richland is very selective about its
heroes
it doesn't revere contemplative monks
wise sages of philosophers glamour is
monopolized by wealth creators
especially ones in films they're doing
that constantly reported on so that the
lives of most ordinary people seem
really squalid and awful by comparison
news of the famous means that people try
much much harder to work and improve
their apparently miserable lot rich land
is seen as a very fair place if you work
hard in a clever you'll get there
there's no nepotism or insider trading
the playing field is level
that's a lovely philosophy for the
winners but more punitive for those who
get left behind they are termed losers
and adjudged personally responsible for
their own shortcomings it's a culture
that's very hostile to the idea of luck
you're the author of your own fate if
things go wrong don't blame anyone else
there's a very high suicide rate in
richland in Richland there's no religion
that energetically promotes spiritual
goods and sees kindness or wisdom as
superior to wealth or power in general
people are secular and Mock the
religious but insofar as some people do
believe that God they believe in is
remarkably materialistic it's a chap in
the sky who believes in rewarding those
who are good with dollops of money
[Music]
Richland has very bad weather it
combines the worst of England and the
Netherlands brief mild unreliable
summers with only around 7 cloudless
days in it and with a temperature rarely
getting into the 20s then come long
endless dark winters with gusty icy
winds and low heavy plow as a result the
natural world delivers a constant
reminder that the light is never freely
and bountifully provided by nature good
things don't grow on trees
only unremitting human industry can
provide salvation
the citizens of Richland can certainly
be envied for their wealth their
shopping malls are extraordinary and
their restaurants truly superlative but
they do also have to be a little pitied
for some of their 4 a.m. anxieties for
their relentless doubts about their
careers and for the worry that no one
can really like them outside of what
they've managed to achieve this quarter
you